Відповідь Кремля на нові санкції США проти Москви не забарилися:
Росія зажадала від американців
аби ті до першого вересня скоротили 755 співробітників американських дипустанов.
Крім того, вже з першого серпня дипмісія США у Росії
втрачає дві будівлі - склад у Москві та дачу в Срібному бору.
Я подумав, що пора нам показати
що ми теж нічого залишати не будемо
Що конкретно стоїть за цими погрозами?
Держдеп США наразі не розголошує інформацію
щодо кількості своїх дипломатів за кордоном.
За інформацією російської сторони
в американському посольстві у Москві та трьох генконсульствах
в Санкт-Петербурзі, Єкатеринбурзі та Владивостоці - працюють 1210 осіб
Утім, переважна більшість з них - росіяни
які мають тимчасові контракти і виконують найрізноманітніші функції
від водіїв, прибиральниць та сантехніків до співробітників візових відділів
американської школи, а також низки російсько-американських проектів співпраці
які фінансуються 35-ма різними державними агентствами США
Так, чотири роки тому в диппредставництві США у Росії лише чверть
триста осіб - були  американськими громадянами.
Решту понад 900 співробітників становили росіяни.
Таким чином саме російські громадяни можуть
виявитися першими кандидатами на скрочення.
Зменшення працівників дипустанов означатиме також і те
що на отримання амеркианських віз росіянам доведеться чекати в рази довше
Так вважає колишній посол США в Росії Майкл Макфол.
Крім того, скорочення штату означатиме й згортання деяких напрямків діяльності американців
що заторкне зрештою теж інтереси російських громадян
як-от програми обміну, освітні та гуманітарні проекти
Нагадаємо, в грудні минулого року Барак Обама
вислав із США 35 російських
російських дипломатів з родинами через втручання
Москви в перебіг президентських виборів у США.
Також конфіскували 2 російські посольські дачі.
Такі взаємні дипломатичні демарші стали
найбільшою кризою у двосторонніх відносинах
з 1986-го року
коли Вашингтон звинуватив у шпигунстві та вислав
понад 70 радянських дипломатів
а Москва натомість заборонила американському
посольству в Росії наймати співробітників-росіян.